Film Courage: How many pitch meetings will
an executive usually have in one day?
Because [as a screenwriter looking to pitch]
we’re going in, we’re ten minutes early,
we’ve got our best outfit on, business casual
(I don’t know what we’re wearing?) but
something that makes us feel comfortable,
we’re ready, this is the biggest deal to
us, but this person [we are pitching to] has
already seen how many people beforehand?
Carole Kirschner: When I was at CBS in comedy
development we would meet with people at 10:00
a.m., 11:00 a.m., 12:00 p.m., 3:00 p.m., 4:00
p.m. and 5:00 p.m.
So here’s a tip: get the early morning meeting.
Do not get a late afternoon meeting.
Especially don’t get a late afternoon meeting
on Fridays.
If you can get a morning meeting, that is
the best way to do it.
Executives are experienced at taking meetings,
they know how to do that.
So if you have to get an afternoon meeting,
it’s not going to sink you.
But your pitch has to be great.
If your pitch is great then they will come
alive because they are looking for great pitches
because it makes their job easier.
So if you have an engaging pitch, they will
come alive.
If the pitch is boring in the late afternoon,
it’s harder to pay attention to it.
Film Courage: Let’s talk about working on
your pitch.
Because, again we see ourselves one way, others
see us another way.
Are we coming up for a script for our pitch?
Or is it better to be spontaneous?
Carole Kirschner: Don’t be spontaneous!
It should be rehearsed.
It’s a performance.
It shouldn’t be memorized from within an
inch of its life, that is not a good idea.
You should know it backwards and forwards
and sideways.
Then put away the paper (although you can
have notes if you want) and then make it a
conversation.
Do not leave it to “I’m just going to
walk in and do this.”
No.
It’s like people in school.
You want to be an overachiever.
Be completely prepared.
Not memorized but completely prepared.
I have a former mentee who sold a lot of pilots
scripts.
She never goes in [to pitch] unless she’s
practiced eight times.
She practices in front of people.
She practices in front of a mirror.
She practices and practices.
There was a writer/producer who was phenomenal
named Stephen Cannell.
He was the most prolific television producer
and creator in the business.
He was always practicing his pitch.
I knew his daughter and she said “You know,
we couldn’t go to the store without him
pitching.”
If he was walking down the hallway in his
building, he would buttonhole you and tell
you the pitch and ask for feedback.
Practice, practice, practice.